voilà maintenant place au cinéma grande
déferlante avec demain le dernier film
de kubrick et puis surtout vous
connaissez la série les incorruptibles
et bien il ya un remake des
incorruptibles avec brian de palma
robert de niro dans le rôle d'al capone
et surtout sean connery le portrait de
sean connery jean chatel
sean connery jimmy mohlala oui qu'on n'y
croyait pas avec un nom pareil conneries
comment voulez vous êtes peu au sérieux
en france et pourtant depuis son
apparition dans mon coloc torno on a
appris à le connaître
sean connery les pains dits commode
pas commode du moins à l'écran car dans
le calme de savate des baléares sean
connery se révèle l'homme le plus
charmant du monde pour nous rappeler ici
quelques-uns de ses meilleurs films
il apparaît dès 1957 au milieu de toutes
les stars du jour le plus long
ensuite des créations aussi superbe que
la colline marni de hitchcock
l'homme qui voulut être roi sean connery
sait qu'il doit tout ça tourne 07 10
depuis il ya eu aussi highlander que
vous voyez ici et encore le nom de la
rose l'acteur s'est hissé au niveau des
plus grands belle réussite pour cet
écossais d'été mlle qui a fait tous les
métiers et s'est même présentée au
concours de monsieur univers à londres
en 1950 le réalisateur brian de palma a
traité ce et incorruptible comme un
western où la violence est stylisée sur
l'écran très la violence fait la
promotion de la violence
sorti de cette violence sean connery
redevient la douceur même pour évoquer
sa femme la française micheline qui en a
fait ce tableau rencontré au maroc
sur un parcours de bravo mr connerie en
25 ans de carrière c'est un sans faute
ou commander sur les terrains de golf
c'est un birdie